he's Josh Jacobs here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you Josh I'm doing good
thanks for having what's going through
your temples right now a week away from
the NFL Draft Josh I'm just honest okay
um this whole process honestly what are
you soaking in just the media side and
meeting with teams and just traveling
and seeing a lot of things
it's definitely huge I'm in uh mute New
York right now doing a media tour which
I got uh Jeff dia and uh just to be a
mother yes the NFL Network he's
following you around
Jeff's following you right now is Jeff
in the room right now yeah well you tell
them to back off that this is my moment
Josh would you tell them just telling
that right now come on okay so basically
the NFL Network is watching you being
interviewed by a guy who who's been with
the NFL Network since day one that's
basically what sitting right now okay
it's a lot of NFL Network all right so
Josh let's get into your your story here
is it true that you had to post your own
highlights to Twitter to get noticed by
colleges is that a fact yes that is in
fact what what led you to do that I'm so
a random guy that takes his name of Cody
Smith um he hit me up and he's like he
stumbled upon my highlights or whatever
you I don't understand why you're not
getting recruited um but you should make
a Twitter and for solids he's like I may
help you get recruited and then like two
or three days later again cause my ten
different teams are media outlets and
stuff so it was crazy so that's under
your current handle of I am underscore
Josh Jacobs that was created essentially
to get your your film out there to be
seen yeah yeah this is that it was
amazing why were you not recruited do
you think I honestly do not know I mean
I passed the qualifications for like a
CT and stuff like that in my sophomore
year of high school led to stay and rest
in my senior and uh never been in
trouble or anything like that so I
honestly did not know it were
seems trying to convert you into
defender or anything like that just say
that you couldn't play the potion you
wanted no only T the only school that's
how to do that was TC UTC you wanted me
to play corner but yeah I wasn't I'm
gonna fill in that defensive move well
no well so what were they telling you
TCU
what did they tell you he told me uh
basically it was it was a crazy story
because I end up getting a tool to do
because he was like we want to offer you
to play corner and I thought oh my I
don't really feel comfortable playing
defense so I don't think I'm gonna take
this offer and he was like it's okay
it's a thousand guys like you and I go
get themselves like all right cool go
get no kidding it was just a coach who
told you that
you know the defensive back coach at the
time or recruiting I was one of them but
uh yeah I remember it like it was
yesterday he was the only one I have
problems with out of everybody so it was
crazy
well obviously they have a problem with
Nick Saban when did he first knock on
your door Josh when did you hear from
from him he came like two and a half
three weeks before sauna days um and I
actually he actually didn't come to uh
to my school to visit me or anything
like he didn't sit in my house and
nothing like that uh coach burns the
running back coach it um came in and
talked to me watch me play basketball
and then you just decided okay when they
offered you you're gonna go play for
Nick Saban in Alabama
is that what oh yeah it was it was more
proving a point alone like I always made
hundred hundred or so it was his proven
to myself that I could play on the
biggest age with the best people well
and in terms of being an underdog you
know your personal life as well
is-is-is character building to say the
least or it first for you others it
might have derailed obviously what is
about to become an NFL career of note so
I what what can you tell me about
because I know that you you've said
before that you find it therapeutic to
talk about your history do you think
that has led you to this moment here
Josh
um yeah I mean just everything I've been
to uh being
in a single-parent home with middle of
five sleeping in the car like sleeping
hotels and motels and stuff like that I
mean it's definitely builded me the type
of person I am today not only that just
not having a bed until I got to college
I mean it's just a lot of things I
always had it worked for so that's where
I get like the job and everything from
and your dad would sit in the front seat
while you were in the back sleeping at
night is that yeah is that the case that
what he did and I it's crazy because I
never seen him sleep he used to do do
like every time I wake up he was up when
I was gonna sleep people's up so I never
seen him seat was staying in the car so
what does it mean for you I mean for you
and your dad that you're about to get
drafted atop the NFL Draft here Josh I
mean it's it's huge
it means a lot not only cannot changed
my family generations but it's also
breaking the cycle and of things that we
had and it's just it's just represents a
season of change and a new beginning so
that's that's probably the biggest
things I'd say fun and you're also a dad
too correct yes I am
Brock three years old is that right
braxton pardon me bracket is a old kid
okay so so you you're taking care of a
lot of people Josh does that does that
overwhelm you at any point in time oh
not really because all my family does
that I'm close with none of them asked
me for anything none of them even want
me to do anything for my my pops today
he don't he told me like you don't want
me to do it on for him he won't even let
me do so I mean it's not a big of a
burden as some people may think that
said when you do get your first
professional contract what is the first
thing you're going to buy for your dad
Josh have you thought about that I
honestly don't know you don't know I
probably on are probably pay his rent
for a couple years or something like
that oh so what
let's talk about Josh Jacobs Iran on the
Rich Eisen show who have you met with
which teams do you think are interested
in you here Josh a week out of the draft
I met with the Eagles are met with the
Ravens and I met with the coats those
are the three teams that you have met
with like in terms of flown out like
dinner the whole the whole shebang yeah
okay
yeah I mean those are three teams that
wouldn't you you'd fit he certainly
would fit in I've just been reading
about you to Josh you've been described
as a runner who runs pissed off where do
you think that comes from it I guess it
just comes from being able to take
everything that I'm going through in
life out on the field and without
getting in trouble so it's kind of like
also their therapeutic means so and
what's the most pissed-off Nick Saban's
ever been at you just see the crazy
thing is he's never he's never gotten
mad at me for like doing something wrong
or anything like that the only time he
ever got mad at me is just like
I'm making too many plays on the defense
and he hates when I do better than walk
me through that one more time Josh what
do you mean what are you talking about
well I say VIN he hates because you know
he's a defensive guy sure he he hates
when the offense does better than the
defense at practice so he like
if we like scoring too much on them here
get to throwing the whole hit throwing
his hat cussing out the Eddie and stuff
like that Eddie the referee and stuff
like that just be funny hmm so when
you're too good in practice is when say
yeah with you by the way that is the
greatest humble brag I think I've ever
any good that is a phenomenal Josh you
should tell that story more often what's
the craziest question you were asked at
the compound
see the funny thing is always waiting
for the crazy question and nobody you
know crazy questions know like I don't
know I guess they just didn't do it they
start asking other people around me did
they get any crazy questions they said
they didn't either song oh no all right
before we get to your business here last
one for you
was it like to watch jaylen hurts sit
while to a won the Heisman and then
obviously jaylen came off the bench in a
crucial moment what did what was it like
being a teammate in the middle of all of
that Josh I mean it was crazy because
not only it was like there's making
history like that's never happened
before and the situations that occur but
it just speaks volumes and so Jalen's
character what type of person he is how
his team oriented and um how he worked
to put his stuff in that position that
to be able to finish the game so I guess
that just B's volume stays character
yeah I guess you become an Oklahoma fan
in a little bit
watching him next yeah I got I got a
supportive I mean I got uh support I bet
all right so now you're supporting a
couple of businesses here the X Tech
shoulder pads stadia or shoulder pads
worn by players on all 32 NFL teams
how'd you get associated with these
folks
oh well I talked to some former Alabama
players like Lana college uh Calvin
really Jamaal Adams even talked to him
and they they all like told me that
these are the past that they use so I
looked into them and did a little
research and uh I end up finding out
that they had like they're really light
and flexible and things like that didn't
have XRD technology which is basically a
military-grade homing and uh I tried
them on and I ran into the wall when I'm
a couple of times I was like yeah I know
this I'll be a person and then again as
I mentioned at the top Sleep Number is a
sponsor here of the Rich Eisen show I
talk about them all the time my Sleep
Number setting is sixty by the way Josh
in case you're wondering it must be
something significant for you to be
representing a bed just crazy how to
happen it's amazing right it's so so
what you enjoy sleeping on this sleep
well yes crazy you can even sit on that
bed like you you yes to get sleep like
that better dangerous I'll be I'll be
telling myself like I make sure my
alarms and everything because if I lay
on that bed
well that is just again that is great
man again that that somebody who
understands the importance of sleep and
obviously doesn't take it for granted
having a bed representing Sleep Number
in their 360 smart bet it's it's awesome
Josh congratulations on that
thank you do Pat and good luck I'll see
you in you're going to Nashville right
are you are you oh I will be a thin and
that's okay just yeah will your dad be
there too yeah my whole family if you
come on it's gonna be great I can't wait
to watch your your moment that you have
earned and that you've worked so hard
for Josh actually come true I really
look forward to that and I can't wait to
watch you do your thing in the NFL Thank
You Man means a lot you got it and tell
Jeff Judea the time is now his again
it's just Jacob's prospect for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app